hey this is press tow
Walker today I'm going to share two
really fun puzzles I saw on social
media problem one you have five glasses
stacked on top of each other and the
height from the bottom to the top is
equal to 34
CM then there are two glasses stacked on
top of each other and the height from
the bottom to the top is equal to 19
CM the question is what is the height of
a single glass equal
to problem
two you have a bottle that's in the
standard shape of a wine bottle and it
contains a standard volume of liquid
equal to
750 cubic
cm the height from the bottom to the top
is equal to 27
CM the diameter of this bottle is equal
to to 8
cm the bottle is basically a perfect
cylinder except for the dimple punt at
the bottom and the shoulder and neck at
the
top the thickness of the bottle is
negligible you could think about it to
be a flimsy plastic
bottle now this bottle is filled with
some liquid and this measures 14 cm from
the bottom
this exact bottle with this liquid is
flipped upside down and the measurement
from the bottom to the top of the liquid
is now equal to 19 CM the question is
what is the volume of the liquid equal
to I credit Alex boss's puzzle column in
the guardian which is where I saw this
puzzle and slightly adapted the
numbers pause the video if you'd like to
give these problems a try when you're
ready keep watching to learn how to
solve these
[Music]
problems so let's solve problem
one so I think a good way to start is
from the end let's say the height of the
glass that we want to solve for is equal
to the variable
X now when we have two glasses it will
be equal to X plus some additional
height he let's say this height is equal
to H so we know that x + H is equal to
19 now go to the five glasses we're
going to have an H over here we have
another H and another H so compared to
the 19 CM case we have three more H
variables so we know that 19 + 3H is
equal to the total height of
34 so let's just focus on these two
equations in two
variables from 19 + 3 H is equal to 34
subtract 19 from both sides to get 3 H
is equal to 15 and then dividing both
sides by three gives H is equal to 5
substituting that into the other
equation gives x + 5 is equal to 19 and
that means X is equal to 14 so the
answer is the height of the glass is
equal to 14 cm and that's the answer to
problem
one let's now solve problem
two so how are we going to find the
volume of the
liquid let's start out with the original
bottle now if the entire bottle was a
perfect cylinder we could calculate its
volume from the textbook
formula so a cylinder with a diameter of
8 C CM will have a radius that's half of
that which is equal to 4
cm the height of the cylinder will be
the height of the bottle which is
27 so the volume of a cylinder is equal
to the area of its base times its height
the area of its base is piun R 2 so the
volume is equal to piun r^ 2 * H in this
case r is equal to 4 and H is equal to
27 so substituting in and then
simplifying gives the volume of the
cylinder is 4
432 Pi but we know the bottle is not a
perfect cylinder it has a dimple Punt
and it has a shoulder and a neck so how
do we account for
that so let's set up some variables for
these
volumes let's say the amount that's
missing at the top will be equal to U
it'll be the upper volume and let's say
this volume at the bottom will have a
volume equal to B
so we now know that if we take 432 pi
and we subtract U and we subtract B
that'll be the volume of the
bottle but the volume of the bottle is
exactly equal to 750 cubic cenm that's
given so we have 432 piun minus uus B is
equal to
750 so let's take this equation and put
it to the
side now let's look at the case where we
have the bottle standing on its bottom
and the liquid goes 14 cm from the
bottom so what is the volume of the
liquid let's say this is a variable
V we can calculate V as if we had a
perfect cylinder and then we would
subtract out the volume that's not there
so here we would have a cylinder with
the radius that's equal to 4 and a
height that's equal to
14 then we need to subtract out this
volume which which we've labeled as B so
the volume of the liquid is equal to < *
4^ 2 * 14us B this simplifies to be 224
Pi minus
B now the trick in this problem is when
we flip the bottle upside down it's
going to be the same volume so we will
calculate the volume in another
way so now we are going to flip the
bottle upside down and now we have
another way that we can calculate the
volume of the liquid
so let's imagine we had a perfect
cylinder with the radius equal to four
and a height equal to
19 then we're going to subtract this
volume which is U so the volume of the
liquid will be exactly the same and in
this case it will be equal to > * 4^ 2 *
19 - U this simplifies to be 304 piun -
U we now have three equations in three
variables but we need to solve for
V so what we'll do is we'll add the two
equations that are equal to V so we get
2 V is equal to 528 piun - uus B but
from the other equation we can solve
that minus U minus B is equal to 750 -
432 piun we can substitute that into the
equation that's equal to 2v so we
substitute this value in and we get that
2v is equal to 528 piun + 750 - 432 Pi
this equation simplifies to be 750 + 96
Pi dividing both sides of the equation
by 2 gives that V is equal to 375 + 48
Pi which is approximately equal to
52580 cubic cm and we've solved for the
volume of the liquid
now this is the correct answer but let's
think about it for a
minute what does this volume
represent
375 is exactly half of
750 so that's half the
bottle what is 48 pi equal to well if we
had a cylinder with a radius of four and
a height equal to 3 that would be a
volume of 48 pi and that's exactly the
same as 3 cm of this liquid in the
middle of the bottle so 48 Pi is also
equal to this so we have calculated the
correct answer but thinking about the
answer has led to another
puzzle why is the volume of the liquid
such a simple answer why is it equal to
half the bottle plus 3 cm of liquid in
the
middle it's these kinds of questions
that Inspire mathematicians to think of
alternate ways to solve the problems I'm
going to share a wonderful solution that
was probably thought of by mathematical
genius so the real trick in solving this
problem is to drink a small amount of
liquid so to understand why let's first
calculate the amount of air that's in
each bottle the total height of the
bottle is 27 cm and in the first case
there's 14 cm of liquid that means there
will be 27 - 14 which equal 13 of air in
the other bottle there's 19 cm of liquid
which leaves 27 - 19 which equals 8 cm
of
air now the trick is to drink 3 cm of
liquid from both bottles so this will
reduce the amount of liquid by 3 cm in
both
cases now let's try and calculate the
volume of the remaining liquid so let's
adjust the
measurements so in the first bottle the
height will decrease by 3 cm so it goes
to 14 - 3 which is equal to 11 cm in the
other bottle it'll be 19 - 3 which is
equal to 16
cm now how much air is in the first
bottle it will be 27- 11 which is equal
to 16
cm and this is the key detail so let's
take a look at the volume of air in the
first bottle that's 16 cm going from
this neck area to the middle and in the
second bottle we have 16 cm of liquid
going from the neck to this middle area
from here we can see that the amount of
air in the first bottle is exactly equal
to the amount of liquid in the second
bottle but the amount of air plus the
amount of liquid is unchanged between
the two bottles
and the amount of air plus the amount of
liquid is equal to the total volume of
the bottle so we can conclude the amount
of air is equal to the amount of liquid
in each bottle therefore the volume of
each is exactly half of the
bottle the air will be equal to 750 over
2 which is 375 cubic cm and the volume
of the liquid will also be
375 cubic cm
so we figured out the volume of the
liquid after we drank 3 cm but to get
back to the original amount we need to
add back in 3 cm of
liquid so we add in the volume of a
cylinder with the radius equal to four
and a height equal to three this will of
course work out to 48 Pi so the original
volume of the liquid is exactly equal to
375+ 48 Pi which is approximately equal
to
52580 cm cubed and that's the answer
what an amazing way to solve this puzzle
thanks for making us one of the best
communities on YouTube see you next
episode of mind your decisions where we
solve The World's problems one video at
a
time